you know why it doesn't do good I'm not
good at Impressions but this is an
impression you ready
okay this is my impression of the dead
people on the Titanic as the submersible
was approaching their
ship that's good enough all right here
it
goes come join us in our watery
grave
oh that's that's awful the joke is they
all died underwater in the same way like
this one group of people died underwater
and then this other group went down to
see them and they also died underwater
why would you go why' you go to this
place you know this doesn't seem like a
good spot to go and so he's merely
taking a very dark situation that could
be used for really dark comedy and he's
just saying hey look at that but he he
can say hey look at that in a way that
does make you laugh